the mandalorian is back with a vengeance
and there's a lot for fans of classic
star wars to sink their teeth into
from the appearance of the infamous
crate dragon to a certain fan favorite
character emerging at the very end of
the episode
there's a lot to unpack plus that's not
even getting into all of the fun easter
eggs associated with the story taking
place on tatooine
complete with jawas and tuscan raiders
in the first episode of season 2
mando ends up forming a truce of sorts
between the townspeople of mars pelgo
and the raiders in the desert and the
sand people are willing to help
they rain on mine
however while tuscan raiders have been
in the star wars universe since the very
beginning
there's still quite a lot casual fans
don't know about them for starters a lot
of people may be unaware of what a
tuscan raider even looks like
throughout the various star wars
properties tuscan raiders are adorned
with masks gloves and long ropes but
imagine all that clothing makes things
pretty hot considering they're on a
desert planet but the aliens have
probably become accustomed to it by this
point however that still doesn't answer
the question of what a tuscan raider
would look like naked
if that's something you're wondering
about well wonder no more
there have been a few places over the
years where you could have seen what
tuscan raiders look like with their
masks off
maybe believe it or not you can get a
pretty good picture of what a tuscan
raider actually looks like under their
hood
by simply looking to the past over the
years the aliens have made a handful of
massless appearances throughout the star
wars universe the first time a tuscan
was ever seen by fans without a mask was
in the 1997 video game
jedi knight dark forces too there's a
group in the game known as grave tuscans
who appear to have cat-like features
however since it's an old video game
it's hard to get a clear idea of what a
tuscan looks like under the mask without
squinting
some clarity came a few years later when
a half-mast tuscan raider appeared in
star wars republic issue 62.
in this comic book anakin has a
nightmarish vision which includes a
tuscan showing off the left side of its
face
since it's a dream sequence the image is
somewhat distorted
so it's still a little difficult to make
out key characters of this race
that said this depiction isn't
necessarily accurate because it is
entirely possible anakin had no idea
what a tuscan raider looked like
in other words this image could have
been his psyche filling in the blanks
and installing a monstrous creature
there
which would make sense considering they
kidnapped his mother
in other words these images may not be
all that accurate when it comes to
understanding the tuscans
that said another piece of star wars
media may finally solve this mystery in
a different way
anyone who watched the season 1 finale
of the mandalorian knows that din jaren
wasn't born a mandalorian
he was adopted later in life suggesting
that being a mandalorian is more of
something you choose than something you
must be born into
it would certainly make sense
considering that mando's even referred
to his way of life as a religion in the
past
and based on one comic it appears as
though something similar may be going on
with tuscan raiders
in star wars republic issue 59 anakin
encounters asherad hett
who wears tuscan gob that is until he
takes off his mask
revealing himself to be human he goes
into a bit of his backstory
explaining how his mother came to live
with the tuscans a long time ago
later in the comic he reveals that
humans aren't genetically compatible
with tuscans and it is potentially
suggested that these raiders have a
bunch of different races living among
them
of course it's worth pointing out that
these comics are no longer part of the
official canon
so it's not necessarily proof of what
the raiders look like under their masks
still similarly to how we eventually saw
mando without his mask perhaps the show
will eventually show us a tuscan raider
unmasked in all of its glory
and end this mystery for good check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite star wars characters are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]